what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with marvel dark ages yes we
are or yeah i was almost at dark days
[Laughter]
that was a batman story so uh in the
last video that we did uh we basically
talked about how the biggest concern
that all the i guess heroes for lack of
a better word have to contend with while
the room wakanda is this idea that
apocalypse is basically doing apocalypse
things and trying to find a way to
seemingly conquer the world they don't
really know the exact specifications of
his plan but what they do know is they
have to get to europe to find some way
to stop whatever it is that apocalypse
is doing now remember a lot of what tom
taylor relies on when it comes to this
story which is one of the reasons why he
can get away with a six issue story as
opposed to like a maxi series so it's
like 12 issues is really just existing
knowledge on comic book characters by
and large with the exception of jonathan
hickman's run on the x-men apocalypse
hasn't necessarily been a bad guy or a
good guy apocalypse just is kind of on
his own and does his own thing he
believes in like social darwinism so
only the strongest deserves to survive
he doesn't differentiate between heroes
and villains it's just the weak and the
strong so in apocalypse's world there
wouldn't really be a difference between
somebody like let's say doctor octopus
and somebody like spider-man that the
reality is if doctor octopus is too weak
to make it in the new world doctor
octopus would die if spider-man was too
weak to make it in this new world
spider-man would die and that would
basically be it so in some ways and
really in more of like a like a moral
philosophical way he's pretty far beyond
the traditional heroes as we normally
see them he is as far beyond mutants as
they are beyond you he is eternal
[Laughter]
now for those of you guys who don't know
that was one of the phrases that
apocalypse had in x-men the animated
series and i always loved it uh it was
he had like the best lines in that show
uh but the thing about this is that in
order to figure out what it is that
they're going to do and how it is that
they're going to to get there they end
up relying on what is in effect the
transport system that gets what are
basically refugees from europe to africa
now this is one of the things to keep in
mind and in fact this is largely tom
taylor borrowing heavily from the events
of age of apocalypse and the reason why
is because despite all of apocalypse's
wanted power and his intelligence at the
end of the day he is not just
all-encompassing those individuals who
know the correct routes who know where
to go who know you know how to how to
sneak away essentially they can escape
the reign of apocalypse and it's one of
those things that marvel always kind of
brought in to establish this idea that
yes apocalypse is powerful the
apocalypse is capable he's certainly not
somebody you want to mess with on any
given day but he's not all seen right
there are some things even he simply
just doesn't know and so that's what's
really going on here that there was a
helicarrier that belonged to shield but
when the power went out of course the
helicarrier's traditional method of
transportation stopped working as well
and so what it did is it actually led to
moon girl coming up with this genius
idea that what they needed was one
someone strong enough to be able to drop
anchor for the helicarrier because this
anchor is just colossal and scale
leading to them using colossus
right the only real super strong guy
they have at their disposal which really
begs the question where's the incredible
hulk in all of this and the other thing
they use is a mode of transportation
that's actually organized by storm
herself that what they've done is
they've set up sails on this ship and
then storm basically provides the wind
to blow it in any particular direction
otherwise they would have to rely on the
way sailors used to travel so if if it
was something like where they wanted to
go north where i guess in this instance
they're traveling to wakanda so they
want to go
east southeast my geography is horrid
i've always been terrible at geography
like they're coming from portugal for
the longest time i thought portugal was
in south america right like i'm sorry we
as americans are terrible with geography
i don't know about you guys in other
countries but the thing about this is
that in in way back in the olden days if
sailors wanted to go east and the winds
were blowing west then they would
literally have to let up their sails
right like put their sails away and just
sit and wait for the wind to start
blowing east and then when the wind
started blowing east they would let
their sails back down and then they
would just ride the wind uh with storm
at their at their side literally the
winds blow whatever direction she wants
them to
which is cool right and so ultimately
with all these refugees about a hundred
thousand people they end up on the
shores of africa specifically wakanda
and the funny thing about this is of
course storm and t'challa are still
together thank god i'm so glad this is
something that they maintained i don't
know how many of you guys read what was
it it wasn't civil war that was when
they got married was it secret invasion
it was one of those stories where um
black panther runs up on storm and he's
like the high priest of wakanda has
nullified our marriage and she's like
aren't you the high priest and he's like
i gotta go and like like that's how he
divorces her he's just like we're done
and then just leaves and that's
basically it uh it's cool to see they're
still together because i gotta be honest
with you guys man storm and t'challa are
like the one-two punch of married
couples in marvel comics right it's just
they're at the top
i always loved the idea of storm and
t'challa being together uh but the cool
thing about this is that one while they
are married two they've got a baby they
got a little kid which is awesome right
it's really really cool to see and
there's a little bit of banter back and
forth between the two which is one of
the things that i always loved about the
marriage between storm and uh in
t'challa is neither one of them puts up
with the others nonsense and so like
when t'challa starts acting a little big
for his britches or when storm starts
doing the same thing they're right there
to be like haha you need to bring it
down a notch
i just love the way their relationship
is written i just love the way it's
handled in marvel comics of course news
is also dropped kind of indirectly to
storm that okoye is basically out of the
picture the details aren't necessarily
given to us on you know in the comic but
we already know right okoye was killed
by quicksilver when he was being
controlled by the purple man so that
information is of course passed to uh to
storm as well but at that point that's
when the revelation kind of comes in
when it's like we need to head back to
europe at that point there's a couple
things that go on here one and this is
one of the things that was kind of given
to us early on if you're on a
helicarrier and you're moving a hundred
thousand people that's a lot of people
and when you're talking about having
like the full crew necessary in order to
run a helicarrier that's even more
people probably more that can fit on a
single helicarrier right or a single
aircraft carrier and so what they did is
they actually invoked multiple man jimmy
madrox so that when the ship or when the
boat needs to be ready to make sale he
can just duplicate himself several times
over in order to ensure that
everything's working the way that it's
supposed to and when that's done
everything's just kind of on the move he
just brings them all back to his normal
self it's a pretty elegant solution but
the other thing about this is you
basically have nick fury who's
essentially you know piloting the ship
or at least the one running the show and
then it seems like you have nightcrawler
as a second in command which is cool i
gotta say pirate nightcrawler looks
pretty dope but when the whole situation
is given to nick fury like apocalypse is
doing something in europe we gotta get
to europe we gotta find out what he's
doing and we have to basically find a
way to stop him because if his
apocalypse he's not up to any good he's
not doing anything to make the world
better if anything he's gonna make like
he's gonna make life hell on all of us
like we gotta find out what it is that
he's doing after he kidnapped tony stark
he's got reed and all these guys we
gotta find out what's happening
initially nick fury is very hesitant
because he's like we literally just
sailed all the way from portugal to
africa and you want us to go back not
only that storm was basically pushing
the sails the entire time so like you
want storm to push us back like i don't
know if i'm down for this but at the end
of the day the case that's made by susan
storm is look either we can go with you
or we can go without you but like one
way or another we're going and the
response to nick fury is no like here's
the thing if you go by yourself there's
no way there's no guarantee you would
even survive against any of the major
heavy hitters that exist out there in
the water right like the raiders name or
the submariner any of the monsters that
exist because one of the things we also
have to contend with is that with the
world collapsing the way that it has
most likely monster island has broken
free those guys who don't know monster
island is basically the place where like
all these different monsters from marvel
comics just sort of hang out they just
chill i don't know what they do play
ping pong watch reruns of global guts no
idea but regardless of the situation
like that's you know without any kind of
technological advancement the world is
essentially free reign and so that's the
concern that fury has is like it would
be a pointless rescue mission to get
there and try to get tony stark if
you're drown or if you're captured or
any number of things and so he's like
okay look if this is what we're going to
do storm i need to know if you're in for
it uh and storm's like yeah she's like
i'm literally the queen of wakanda and
if we're talking about apocalypse doing
something that threatens the world then
it means it also threatens my people and
my country therefore we are going and so
storm of course fills the sails and the
ship ends up on its way and it's a
really really cool moment here because
you get a couple things going on right
some discussions and so on but one of
the bigger talking points here really
comes from doctor doom when he's with
jessica jones and luke cage and and uh
in x-23 or wolverine and with uh
spider-man and so on and the big
question that he talks about here is
this like okay so the nature of this
mission is yes it's a rescue mission for
tony stark but let's be honest we will
probably never get a better shot than to
kill apocalypse in this moment right now
right if we go to europe we rescue tony
stark and we leave apocalypse will know
that we're capable of that he'll strike
back in some form or fashion right he
may be expecting us to a degree but he
doesn't know under what circumstance to
expect us and he doesn't know how we're
going to appear and so having that
element of surprise is the best chance
we have of taking him out now again this
is the cool thing because i love this
idea of doctor doom discussing how
they're going to kill apocalypse again
more so than that it's like we mentioned
in the last video i love that that
doctor doom is very very careful in how
he deals with apocalypse because under
any normal circumstance doctor doom
would just be like i will take care of
him i will save all of you because i am
doom and i'm better than you all and you
can't save yourselves it's the most
doctor doom thing for him to say but the
fact that he's just like we have to
strike apocalypse i can't kill him on my
own like that kind of a thing it's just
so cool because it really just shows the
gravity of the threat that apocalypse
poses because in the face of a being
that harnesses celestial technology
right those guys who are unfamiliar with
this guy apocalypse can basically do
everything like the long and short of
this is with the exception of being able
to alter reality on really any level he
can give himself essentially any
superhuman power and he has it he has
size alteration he can emit energy
blasts he can make himself intangible he
can teleport he can make him he can
increase his mass make himself insanely
durable right to the point where it's
almost on the same level as vision if
not more so he's got telepathy he's got
telekinesis the guy can do it all right
he's just a one-man killing machine if
he wants to be he quite literally lives
up to his namesake but the biggest
concern that like spider-man and
wolverine and all these people have is
knowing doctor doom as they know him
it's so if we do this victor von doom if
we invade europe and we kill apocalypse
who do you suppose should be the leader
of europe and doctor who picks up on
this immediately and he's like look if i
wanted to rule a nation i would have
taken wakanda i've done it before and he
has it was a story called do-more
but he's like if i wanted to do that i
could do that but that's not really my
goal here the problem is we don't really
find out exactly what it is that dr doom
is shooting for because there's this
kind of just blood curdling scream that
comes from spider-man's daughter may
who's not supposed to be there but as
any good child does one her curiosity
got the better of her and two she snuck
aboard the ship
which of course we kind of knew was
gonna happen when he was like you have
to stay here at the same time it's also
like luke cage and jessica jones
daughter and it's just like what are you
even doing i mean that's the thing right
they're kids they're supposed to be
stupid right they're supposed to make
bad decisions they're learning
they're pushing barriers and so on and
so forth as they get older they will
realize how dumb of a mistake this was
assuming they live long enough to get
older but the thing about this is that
the reason why she was screaming is her
spider sense was kicking off and so is
peter parker's peter parker spider-sense
kicks off at the same time and at that
moment nick fury is impaled by what's
basically a hook and then yanked over
the side of the ship and that's when the
ghost raiders appear now these guys are
cool and i'm gonna be honest with you
guys i would read a one-shot story about
these dudes i would like i would read a
one-shot tie-in to the ghost raiders all
we're really told here is that when the
world went dark right when that emp
started blanketing everything and power
was lost there were just pirates who
were out there in the ocean with no real
means of going anywhere and were by all
standards of measurement stranded so
they were quite literally just counting
the days until they die unless they turn
to sea water and then they probably
would have discounted less days because
they would have died faster but in an
act of desperation as usually happens in
this situation they turn to mephisto who
actually most likely appeared to them
but they ended up basically making
bargains with mephisto selling their
souls and they ended up becoming what
are in effect ghost riders instead and
what they do here is they literally just
sail around the ocean and any poor soul
who ends up straying across their path
is basically drugged down to the deaths
and drown where they're set on fire at
the same time but they're drowned and as
a result of that they end up basically
passing on to mephisto right you know
and mephisto builds his numbers down in
hell or whatever it is and so the crazy
thing here is of course you end up
getting fastball specials which is cool
like those you guys who don't know what
that is those are guys who aren't old
school enough to know what that is the
fastball special originated in uh really
following giant size x-men where
colossus would throw wolverine whenever
it was a target that wolverine was
trying to hit that was exceedingly far
away he wouldn't be able to get there in
time or it was really high up uh
literally colossus would just grab
wolverine and throw him at it it was
really cool to see it was just one of
those little hallmark moments right from
from the old x-men stories well now
that's going on with both x23 and uh and
gabby which is awesome to see right it's
really really cool to see and so of
course the other thing that we get here
and there's this is a ridiculously cool
moment one the ghost raiders have their
own ship which looks amazing and two
they've got mini guns man shooting fire
bullets i want to see a one shot like i
want to see a comic that focuses on
these guys because it's just amazing but
for the most part with you know
regarding everybody else of course susan
storm pops a force field protects people
things along those lines you end up
having uh basically nightcrawler who
teleports aboard the ship trying to
destroy them or at least trying to save
people but in the middle of this what
they're trying to do at least the the
heroes anyway they're trying to get to
the guardians of the port right the
guardians of the port that will
essentially help anybody out there who
is dealing with basically any threat
whether it's name with a submariner or
or any of these guys and ultimately that
happens and it happens with the
emergence of
which is cool like he literally just
comes flying out of the ocean which is
absolutely amazing and when like when
peter's daughter is just like freaking
out it's just like no no it's okay may
and she's like it's a monster and he's
like yeah you know it's the guardian of
the port
right like like what he says is finn
thank fume was our monster and the
reason why finn fang foom is on the side
of heroes again for lack of a better
word is because it's not just finn fang
fume it's actually scott lang and finn
fang fume working together and the
reason why is because remember when
everything shut down because scott
lang's ability to utilize the ant-man
tech of shrinking or growing is based on
technology right based on power when the
power went out he was stuck in giant
size mode so he's just giant he's just a
huge guy and it's cool to see scott lang
riding a dragon
[Laughter]
and burning the ghost raiders and
destroying their ship and sitting them
back down to the depths and so again
this is this is in truth probably one of
the weaker issues because the way this
ends is really everybody just sort of
mulling over and acknowledging the fact
that nick fury has essentially died but
at the end of the day the mission must
go on now i will say this the next one
issue five and especially issue six
especially when you find out what's
going on with the new symbiont that's
nuts dude the new symbiote is oh my god
it's amazing but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later peace